foreign
[Music]
Tomatoes know as much as we love them
not everyone always sees eye to eye
especially when talking about the
reception of a movie from critics and
audiences the discussion can get a
little tomato tomato but we believe
that's what makes movies so great their
ability to inspire disgust bring joy and
anger maybe all at the same time which
is why today we wanted to look at some
of these movies that are a hot pot of
debate between fans and critics being
both rotten and loved by audiences you
go anywhere in the city preying on
innocent people and we will find you and
eat
in both of your legs and then we will
eat your face right off your hand do you
understand
yes so you will be this honest legless
faceless thing won't you rolling down
the street
and the wind
do you feel me for this list we're
focusing on the audience score in order
to make our list each film had to be
rotten so 60 or below from critics with
a score of 70 or higher from the
audience Anne had to have a difference
of at least 30 percent between the two
so get on your boxing gloves cause it is
time for a showdown as we count down our
list of fan favorite rotten movies
foreign
[Music]
number 10 Fantastic Beasts the secrets
of Dumbledore Professor Albus Dumbledore
knows the powerful dark wizard Gellert
Grindelwald is moving to seize control
of the Wizarding World unable to stop
him alone he entrusts magic zoologists
Newt scamander to lead an Intrepid team
of wizards witches and one Brave muggle
Baker on a dangerous mission where they
encounter old and new beasts and clash
with grindelwald's growing Legion of
followers but with the stakes so high
how long can Dumbledore remain on the
sidelines starring Eddie Redmayne Jude
Law mads Mickelson and directed by David
Yates audiences say it's a little long
and the effects might be better than the
story but for fans of the franchise this
is a fairly fantastic sequel
Let It Go
excuse me
foreign
number nine the greatest showman growing
up in the early 1800s PT Barnum displays
a natural talent for publicity and
promotion selling lottery tickets by age
12. after trying his hands at various
jobs PT turns to show business to
indulge his Limitless imagination rising
from nothing to create the Barnum and
Bailey Circus featuring catchy musical
numbers exotic performers and daring
acrobatic Feats Barnum's mesmerizing
spectacle soon takes the World by storm
to become The Greatest Show on Earth
starring Hugh Jackman Michelle Williams
Zendaya Zac Efron and directed by
Michael Gracie audiences say the story
might not be anything special but if
it's a singing dancing extravaganza that
you seek the greatest showman delivers
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
I want to introduce my newest hire Mr
Phil Carlisle
it's a pleasure to meet you yeah
pleasure
and what is your act Mr Carla
I don't have an actor
everyone's gotten it
number eight Star Wars the rise of
Skywalker
when it's discovered that the evil
Emperor Palpatine did not die at the
hands of Darth Vader the rebels must
race against the clock to find out his
whereabouts Finn and Poe lead the
resistance to put a stop to the first
order's plans to form a new Empire while
Rey anticipates her inevitable
confrontation with kylo Ren warning some
flashing light scenes in this film may
affect photosensitive viewers starring
Carrie Fisher Mark Hamill Adam Driver
Daisy Ridley and directed by JJ Abrams
audiences say for Star Wars fans unhappy
with the previous sequel rise of
Skywalker concludes this phase of the
franchise on a relative high note
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
number seven ticket to Paradise Academy
Award winners George Clooney and Julia
Roberts reunite on the big screen as
exes who find themselves on a shared
mission to stop their Lovestruck
daughter from making the same mistake
they once made from working titles
Smokehouse pictures and red ohm films
ticket to Paradise is a romantic comedy
about the sweet surprise of Second
Chances starring George Clooney Julia
Roberts Caitlyn Dever and directed by
old Parker audiences say Ayla Stars
beautiful scenery and lighthearted
rom-com story what else could you want
from ticket to Paradise excuse me ma'am
I think your things are in myself oh I'm
sorry
oh come on you've got to be kidding me
English or you're still doing the
Italian tourist bit excuse me ma'am I
need to sit somewhere else I'm sorry
it's a full flight we used to be married
the worst 19 years of my life we were
only married for five account in the
recovery
there's nothing I can do
just remember in case we go down
you owe me one
I told you I was going to go get her in
four days time our daughter's gonna
marry a guy she just met millions of
miles from home excuse me did the middle
of my sentence interrupt the beginning
of yours champagne
just leave the bottle
thank you number six Lion King 2019.
Simba idolizes his father King Mufasa
and takes to Heart his own Royal Destiny
on the plains of Africa but not everyone
in the Kingdom celebrates the new Cubs
arrival scar Mufasa's brother and former
heir to the throne as plans of his own
the battle for Pride Rock is soon
ravaged with betrayal tragedy and drama
ultimately resulting in Simba's Exile
now with the help from a curious pair of
Newfound friends Simba must figure out
how to grow up and take back what is
rightfully his starring Donald Glover
Seth Rogen chuatel ejiofor Alfrey
Woodard and directed by John Favreau
audiences say Disney Live Action remake
that successfully updates the original
The Lion King adds gorgeous new visual
effects to a story the audience Knows by
heart this Gorge is where all lions come
to find their role all lions even my dad
even Mufasa came here when he was your
age
refused to leave until his Roar could be
heard
Above the Rim
all the way up there that's when you
know you found it for the little
practice
you'll never be called a cub again
watch this
you'll get it Simba
just takes time
I'll check on you later
that would be so proud Loney
it's a gift he'll never forget
number five Black Adam nearly 5 000
years after he was bestowed with the
almighty powers of the ancient gods and
imprisoned just as quickly Black Adam is
freed from his Earthly tomb ready to
unleash his unique form of Justice on
the modern world starring Dwayne Johnson
Aldous Hodge Noah centineo and directed
by Jean Colette Sarah audiences say with
lots of action solid effects and a story
you don't have to be a Comics fan to
follow Black Adam is one of the best DC
movies to date
foreign
[Music]
Number Four The Gray Man when the cia's
most skilled mercenary whose true
identity is known to none accidentally
uncovers dark agency Secrets a
psychopathic former colleague puts a
bounty on his head setting off a global
Manhunt by International assassins
starring Ryan Gosling Chris Evans Anna
De armas and directed by Anthony and Joe
Russo audiences say add this one to your
cue with confidence action fans the gray
man has a great cast exciting set pieces
and a solid story
oh man hey sunshine
um you must be Lloyd what gave it away
the White Pass the trash Dash It's just
it leans Lloyd
ways to drive
somewhere this is hard to see you then
is that in
here
[Music]
oh
my God
tougher spray
nice try pumpkin I'm so sure you why you
want my foot
looks like an 11. number three Uncharted
Street Smart Thief Nathan Drake is
recruited by seasoned treasure hunter
Victor Sully Sullivan to recover Fortune
lost by Ferdinand Magellan 500 years ago
what starts as a heist job for the duo
becomes a globetrotting White Knuckle
race to reach the prize before the
ruthless moncada who believes he and his
family are the rightful heirs if Nate
and Sully can decipher the clues and
solve one of the world's oldest
Mysteries they stand to find five
billion dollars in Treasure and perhaps
even Nate's long-lost brother but only
if they can learn to work together
starring Tom Holland Mark Wahlberg
Sophia Ali tati Gabrielle and directed
by Reuben Fleischer audiences say with
plenty of action and a terrific cast
Uncharted is a solid adaptation of the
games and a fun throwback to classic
adventure movies of the past
hey
hey come on
[Music]
foreign
number two Aladdin 2019 Aladdin is a
lovable street urchin who meets Princess
Jasmine the beautiful daughter of the
Sultan of Agrabah Aladdin stumbles upon
a magic oil lamp that unleashes a
powerful wisecracking Larger than Life
Genie as Aladdin and the genie start to
become friends they must soon embark on
a dangerous mission to stop the evil
sorcerer far from overthrowing Young
Jasmine's Kingdom starring Will Smith
Mina Masood Naomi Scott and directed by
Guy Richie audiences say it's hard to
beat the original Aladdin but this new
version's killer cast terrific
soundtrack and impressive effects add up
to a remake that's plenty entertaining
in its own right
here's the thing about wishes
the more you have
the more you want
that's not me
we'll see about that but there is
something oh
seen that face before who is she who's
the girl
she's a princess oh aren't they all
treat your woman like a queen I always
say no no she's an actual princess well
I already told you I can't make anyone
love anyone no no we had a connection
did they
she is smart and kind and so beautiful
but she has to marry a
hey can you make me a princess there is
a lot of gray area in make me a prince I
could just thank you a prince
oh no right you'll be snuggled up with
that dude for the rest of your life
be specific with your words the deal is
in the detail got it which I don't
really understand because if she already
likes you why change I told you she has
to marry a prince I just want to go home
man and before we reveal number one here
are some honorable mentions
don't worry darling
Jack are lucky to be living in the
idealized community of Victory the
experimental company town housing the
men who work for the top secret Victory
project and their families the 1950s
societal optimism espoused by their CEO
Frank equal parts corporate Visionary
and motivational life coach anchors
every aspect of daily life in the
tight-knit desert Utopia now while the
husbands spend every day inside the
victory project headquarters working on
the development of progressive materials
their wives including Frank's elegant
partner Shelly get to spend their time
enjoying the beauty luxury and
debauchery of their community life is
perfect with every resident's needs met
by the company all they ask in return is
discretion and unquestioning commitment
to the victory cause but when cracks in
her idyllic Life begin to appear
exposing flashes of something much more
Sinister lurking beneath the attractive
facade Alice can't help questioning
exactly what they're doing in Victory
and why just how much is Alice willing
to lose to expose what's really going on
in this paradise starring Florence Pugh
Harry Styles Chris Pine and Olivia Wilde
who also directed the film audiences say
the ending isn't for everyone but the
cast especially Florence Pugh helps
don't worry darling make the most of a
story with fairly few surprises
foreign
[Applause]
Space Jam a new Legacy when LeBron James
and his young son Dom are trapped in a
digital Space by a rogue AI LeBron must
get him home safe by Leading bugs Lola
Bunny and the whole gang of notoriously
undiscible Looney Tunes to victory over
the ai's digitized champions of the
Court a powered up roster of
professional basketball stars as you've
never seen them before it is Tunes vs
goons in the highest Stakes challenge of
his life that will redefine LeBron's
bond with his son and shine a light on
the power of being yourself starring
LeBron James Don Cheadle Cedric Joe and
directed by Malcolm D Lee audiences say
LeBron James probably won't win any
acting Awards but this isn't
entertaining all ages movie with solid
animation a positive message for kids
and fun cameos for older viewers
[Music]
well if it isn't the old news Looney
Tunes
and just as washed up as ever
you know what
I think it's time for an upgrade
an upgrade
[Music]
what in the world
do not do that
I look expensive
[Music]
what's happening
oh no oh they're alive
Venom journalist Eddie Brock is trying
to take down Carlton Drake The Notorious
and Brilliant founder of the life
Foundation while investigating one of
Drake's experiments Eddie's body merges
with the alien venom leaving him with
superhuman strength and power Twisted
dark and fueled by rage Venom tries to
control the new and dangerous abilities
that Eddie finds so intoxicating
starring Tom Hardy Michelle Williams
Riza Med and directed by Reuben
Fleischer audiences say some truly fun
Odd Couple chemistry plus the right
blend of action in comedy make Venom's
messy plot easy to forgive
foreign
I got it bring him home copy that
oh
you have been a serious pain in there
well you know I aim to please
[Music]
eyes
foreign
[Music]
and finally number one where the
crawdads sing
for the best-selling novel comes a
captivating mystery were the crawdads
sing tells the story of Kaya an
abandoned girl who raised herself to
adulthood in the dangerous marshlands of
North Carolina for years rumors of the
marsh girl haunted Barkley Cove
isolating the sharp and resilient kaya
from her community drawn to two young
men from town Kaia opens herself to a
new and startling world but when one of
them is found dead she's immediately
cast by the community as the main
suspect as the case unfolds the verdict
as to what actually happened becomes
increasingly unclear threatening to
reveal the many secrets that lay within
the marsh starring Daisy Edgar Jones
Taylor John Smith Harris Dickinson and
directed by Olivia Newman audiences say
a particular treat for viewers who love
the book were the Crawdad Singh offers a
Faithfully told well-acted story in a
rich beautifully filmed setting
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
well that about does it for us be sure
to stay tuned to the Rotten Tomatoes
channel for more of the entertainment
content you love until next time I'm
your host Naz Perez and we'll see you
back here for more top tens on the
Rotten Tomatoes countdown
[Music]
thank you